long now is set up to help people think
about long-term issues ones that
actually reach out a couple of centuries
and probably none is more clear and
present in that regard than climate
change and so it's an area I've
researched and I've written about been
around most of the serious players and
then along comes a book it's all marked
up that is just full of news to me
and slipped my mind a couple things and
the guy who flipped that mind and might
flip yours here tonight Jeff Goodell
[Applause]
Thank You Stuart
I don't know about flipping minds but
I'll do my best
I'm totally thrilled to be here
in part for very personal reasons which
is that I grew up in Sunnyvale and to be
back here and to talking with you
tonight it feels like a kind of
homecoming for me I'm thrilled to be
here because I've had enormous respect
for Stuart and for everything that the
long now has been doing long now
foundation has been doing over the years
Stuart and I were just talking in the
back room and not only as he has this
sort of long record of helping us
rethink and think differently about in
the environment and the world we live in
but he's also been living in a boat
since what 1983
so there's vision right there about
what's happening right and the third
reason I'm really thrilled to be here is
because I just got back from two months
in Antarctica on a research ship to go
to a very remote part of Antarctica on
West West Antarctica on a joint research
trip with the US and the British to look
at a thing called Thwaites glacier which
is sort of the Cork in the wine bottle
for the big ice sheets in West
Antarctica and his arguably the
most consequential tipping point in our
climate system right now in fact that
picture you're seeing above me there is
a picture of the ice shelf of the
weights glacier we were the first human
beings ever to go there no one had ever
been there before the seabed around
there and everything was complete black
hole when we mapped the seabed we looked
over the water circulation I'll talk
more about that as in the talk but it
was a very profound experience because
that glacier has been sitting there now
our Arctic has been more or less a
stable place for about thirty million
years and we were there to read it to
look at how quickly and how suddenly
this could all collapse and I'll talk
about the dynamics of that but it was a
real exercise in the impact that we are
having on our world in ways that even
someone like me who who thinks about
this a lot doesn't didn't really grasp
and and for me two things were really
clear there one I've actually I really
realized that even people who were
educated about climate change and
understand and read about it have no
idea the scale and complexity of what's
coming our way for me seeing Antarctica
is thinking about these glaciers looking
at them up close was very very profound
and really made me realize that even
though I've been thinking about climate
change and writing about it for 15 years
I really have no had no idea this sort
of immensity of what we're doing to our
planet and Antarctica really showed me
that and the other thing that I saw was
that I think that I would say that the
future of virtually every coastal city
in the world is written in ice is
written in that ice sheet right there
and thinking about that and about what
the implications of that are is sort of
what I'd like to talk about tonight
about how sea-level rise is going to
reshape our world in very profound ways
not just changing the literal map of the
world where the water is where the land
is but also huge economic implications
huge political implications and and and
all that I so I'm gonna try to in a few
minutes give you a quick kind of tour
some thoughts about what I learned in
thinking about that when working on this
book and writing this book which I spent
four or five years on I'm in denial
about how long it really was it was for
if I I'm not sure it was a long time um
but but I wanted to say a little bit
about myself just to give you a sense of
how I came at this I did grow up in
Sunnyvale this is me at the boardwalk in
Santa Cruz and I only talk about this
because because I grew up with a sense
of technological optimism that we can
solve problems you know I was just
visiting my mom yesterday and and I
remember when she came home in the late
70s and said I got a job at this place
this funny little place called Apple
Computer I'm like what you're not
working for a place called Apple are you
seriously that's never gonna last so I
but I was imbued with that spirit it
growing up and I actually worked it out
myself for a little while and and for
the last 15 years I've been writing
writing a rolling stone in longer than
15 years but the last 15 years it's been
focused mostly on climate and energy
stuff and that's what I've had sort of
been my beat
over over time and I've written a number
of books one about the coal industry I
wrote a book about geoengineering
something that we can touch on today and
this latest book called the water will
come about sea level rise which is what
I'm going to talk about tonight and I
want to start with just some thoughts
about about about what I learned while I
was doing this and this whole book sort
of started when I went to Miami and
what's called sunny day flooding when
you go to
when you have in Miami now it's gotten a
little bit better because of some of the
changes they've made but I went to Miami
Beach on a normal high tide day in the
in the fall and there was three feet of
water in the streets and I was like what
is going on here and I spent 15 minutes
thinking about it and looking at it and
became very clear to me that if you take
climate change at all seriously if you
take sea level rise at all seriously
it's very difficult to see what kind of
future place like Miami has a lot of
real estate bill right in the water it's
built on what's essentially Swiss cheese
it's a porous limestone that has holes
in it so it means that you can't build
sea walls like you can another place
because the water goes right up yet on
the other side and you have of course a
political system there that is deep in
in denial and so I wrote a very sorry
for Rolling Stone about the future of
Miami with a very subtle title called
goodbye Miami and that caused a little a
little chaos shall we say I tell my kids
now that if I never like found in a car
with a brake lines cut the kind of Karen
Silkwood thing you know in a ditch
somewhere to go to the miami realtor
association to check it out first
because they're gonna be the ones who
they were really not happy about this
but that riding that piece and thinking
about that made me think okay well so
this is what's happening in miami what's
going on in the rest of the world and
that's where it's sort of where the book
was born and i thought okay this is the
problems in miami what happens in San
Francisco what happens in New York what
happens in in Legos what happens in the
Marshall Islands how are they dealing
with it and I and I traveled around the
world this is a kid I met in Legos which
was a very interesting part of the
journey because I really saw that one of
the problems with thinking about sea
level rise and the consequences of this
is this very modern notion that we have
that the land is here and the sea is
here and forever it shall be and so
we've built a lot of stuff with the idea
that the land is here and the sea is
here and now of course we're realizing
that that's changing
but in simpler places where they'd build
in different ways in you talk to the
this kids family and Legos and you say
what are you gonna do you think about
six feet of sea-level rise they're like
we can raise our house in the afternoon
we can do it tomorrow tell me when you
know it's not a problem because they've
built in a different kind of way right
they don't have big you know hotels in
concrete right on the beach they don't
have giant airports on landfill right on
the water
it's not a problem to adapt in a place
like Legos and that was a very profound
insight to me to see that although
cultures like this that have or that are
not as wealthy as is the world that we
live and have other challenges from a
sort of infrastructure sense they're way
more advanced because they've built in a
kind of more flexible way I went to the
Marshall Islands and looked at what's
happening there for them it's not a
question of like real-estate investment
or losing their favorite Beach sea level
rises an existential crisis it's going
to mean their country is going to vanish
is going to go away and what does that
mean how do you think about that are
they going to have a virtual Marshall
Islands what happens to their fishing
rights what happens to their culture
what happens to their language how do
you preserve that how do you think about
that that's what's happening there now
in places like the Marshall Islands and
other places that are facing a kind of
extinction and they know it from this I
went to Venice of course you can write
about anything like those without going
to Venice and Venice was great you know
Venice as soon as I got there I've been
to Venice before but I got there in this
context today my immediate thought was
this is so fantastic this is how every
city should be you know canals and we
made a mistake building cities on land
this is a perfect paradigm of how it all
should be and in a certain way it is but
Venice is also in big trouble because
not only is it has it been subsided over
time but the waters are the sea level is
rising you're all around to the lagoon
is filling up and filling up and I'll
talk a little bit more
the kind of wall they're building there
but the essential problem in Venice is
that it is an architectural gem and they
can't do anything to change that right I
talked to the chief engineer of the city
and he said 500 years ago they had all
kinds of problems of sidon sand flooding
but they would just build on top of
things and so they would just like knock
something down and build it and the city
got gradually higher and now if you're
trying to build a new building you know
they they drill down and you hit like
Marco Polo's house and then there's like
Marco Polo's dad's house and there's
Marco Polo's grandfather's house and
it's just this layer cake of stuff but
you can't do that anymore you can't nog
you can't touch anything and so it's a
huge problem the city is frozen in amber
and so how do you deal with it then what
do you do and I'll talk a little bit
about what kind of solution that they've
been thinking about I met this guy you
might recognize him we spent three days
in Alaska wandering around talking about
climate change and sea level rise and I
think about that moment sometimes now
and it's very surreal spending you know
three days with the president thinking
talking about climate change and but it
is not as surreal as thinking about that
same trip with our current president
what that would be like that would be
like very different conversation and so
all of this is what I did to kind of put
together this book and to begin thinking
about this and it sort of the biggest
scale that I could and the five things
that I kind of came up with that are I
think are really important to understand
about this world that we're facing in
our future that we're thinking about are
these things one is that storms and
hurricanes are like roulette and
sea-level rise is like gravity it's a
very fundamental difference and people
think about flooding in different ways
but it's this notion that you know we
all watch when hurricanes are coming we
watch the storm tracks and you know
you're lucky if your relatives live or
you live in the unlucky if you live in
the area where it's going to hit or
where it does and it's just like you
watch this thing and it's very dramatic
and everything and then then if you're
hit you're hit in your houses
one it or it's not and then you rebuild
or you don't but it you go back to
normal then you wait for the roulette
ball again and you hope that you know
you have fifty years or a hundred years
before the roulette ball lands in your
neighborhood again sea-level rise is
completely different sea level rise is
inevitable sea level rise is everywhere
it's happening and it doesn't stop the
water doesn't go up and then come back I
mean obviously there are tides but the
tides get higher and higher and higher
and higher and it's this incessant
growth of of elevation of waters that is
fundamentally different and makes it
fundamentally so challenging you know I
think that I mean one way to think about
this is you know we all know that the
earth has 70% of the surface is liquid
water right is oceans and 70% of the
surface but if you think about it yeah
this is a NOAA picture of the earth and
all of the earth's liquid water is in
that one you can put it in that one like
glob there which is about 800 miles in
diameter and we have a fixed amount of
water on the planet there's not a lot
musk is not making more water you know
there's a certain amount that we have
and what happens as our planet warms and
cools as it gets redistributed right so
when our planet cools you get more water
add more ice sea levels go down as our
planet warms we get less ice sea levels
rise this happened many many times in
history this is just a picture of maybe
even many of you know about doggerland
it's just where you could walk from
London to Paris to get a croissant back
in those days this was six thousand ten
thousand years ago and the Seas have
risen now and doggerland is underwater
although people fishing out there still
pull up wooly mammoth bones and things
from from the this doggerland area that
is now underwater but this is a great
example in the Bering Strait of course
everyone knows about the Bering Strait
the connections between what is now
Russia and Alaska migration pattern for
many animals and of course humans also
all of that was related to sea level
right instead the up and down of the
Seas which was related to oscillations
in the Earth's orbit volcanic activity
other things like that but what's
happening now is very different we are
burning fossil fuels and we are cooking
or heating up the planet I just don't
want to go into halt that a whole lot
but I just want to show you this graphic
the many maybe a lot of you have seen
but I think it's just really powerful
and I just want to show you this is a
real-time temperature of the earth from
1880 until now run it really quickly and
you'll see of course that the warming is
in the yellows and oranges and the blue
is the cooling and just watch what
happens has been happening to our planet
basically since we've been burning a lot
of fossil fuels and you can see that up
until now we're still early part of the
century things are just sort of nothing
big change you're starting to see some
warming warmer and watch that watch the
Arctic North the top what happens here a
little bit of an article to put
especially especially the the north and
you see the heating up heating up and
this is not a model this is actual
temperature measurements right so this
is where we are right now so when we
talk about sea level rise the issue is
really to thane two places the arctic
greenland and antarctica there's some
sea level rise in the 20th century has
been because of thermal expansion the
water it gets essentially expands as it
heats up there's some contributions from
mountain glaciers and things land
mountain glaciers and things like that
but it's really the big ice cubes at
each end of the planet that is a big
issue and you can see here that there's
been a lot of heat in in the Arctic and
in Greenland in particular and here you
can see what's happening with that heat
so in just the last 15 years or so four
trillion tons of ice has left Greenland
has melted from Greenland and that's and
you can see this
again satellite this is satellite data
this is not a model this is what's
really happening and all this land-based
ice that is melting is going into the
ocean obviously and this is what's
contributing and will contribute to sea
level rise and you can see that it's
along the coastal area that is the
biggest contributions and so this is
what we're doing to our planet this is
why my book is called the water will
come not the water might come or the
water might come unless everybody you
know sells their SUV and buys a Tesla or
something like that we are setting this
process in motion right now and this is
a drawing I had a scientist give me of
Seward and I were talking about this in
the green room of this is a period in
there is climate three million years ago
when co2 levels were about the same as
they are now about 400 parts per million
temperature was about the same as they
as it is now so this is basically a past
analogue for our climate and this line
here is where the coast was at that time
on the where the East Coast was so what
this means is that we have between 25
and 60 or 70 feet of sea level rise
built in to the system right now this is
not some so if we all stopped emitting
all co2 right now if we just figured out
some miracle way to stop emitting co2 we
would still have 25 to 60 feet of sea
level rise built into the system that
right now that heat is in the ocean as
that radiates out and we reach thermal
equilibrium this is where we're going
question is time scales whether it's
over a century a number of centuries how
long it takes but this is where we are
going and again this is why the book is
called the water will come we're not
going to stop this no matter how good of
citizens we are we're moving into this
world of adaptation of change of
radically refashioning our world and
it's going to continue not just until
2100
is always the number that everybody
talks about but for centuries right this
is this is a long time scale thing the
second big big question and the one that
we were looking at in Antarctica and it
was the main purpose of our trip to
Antarctica is how high the water will
come and how fast it will come it's one
thing if you talk about five or six feet
of sea level rise over 300 years so we
can deal with that you know that's fine
we can slowly move our way away we can
build infrastructure we can do things if
we're talking about Richard alley the
arguably ice scientists at Penn State
arguably I think everybody who knows
anything about climate science would
agree that he's probably the greatest
ice scientist or even climate scientists
around right now he told me a month ago
that we can't rule out 15 feet of sea
level rise by the end of the century so
if you think about the difference
between 15 feet of sea level rise by the
end of the century and 6 feet of sea
level rise over centuries it's a very
different scenario so this rate thing is
what's really really important about
this this is just a quick graph to just
to show you the high end scenarios of
climate models over over the last decade
or so and the only point I want to show
you here is that they're getting higher
and there there's there's a the
uncertainty is moving towards higher
scenarios rather than low the you know
NOAA now then you know top science
agency in the u.s. before it was
decimated by our president had a high
end scenario of 8 feet by the end of the
century and that's sort of where we're
going and a lot of that increased that
climbed that you're seeing there is
because of not Greenland which I just
talked about but Antarctica which I will
talk about but I want to show you just
in your hood here what this means so
obviously this is the bay you know where
this is here and this is this is what's
called a bathtub model so this is
showing you what will happen if we make
no changes we're assuming that there's
no walls put up no no adaptation but
just to give you an idea of what this
looks like so this is current
and that's seven feet which is lower
than the high end scenario for even a
conservative government agency says so
you can see that's a big deal
right new Facebook headquarters big
trouble right look at this now so this
is interesting this is this is obviously
the North Bay and you can see this is
this is today and this is just one foot
of sea level rise one foot so what's
really interesting about this and is
true about sea level rise in general in
stru in Miami is true than many places
at you in the Netherlands also is it the
it it backs up in places that you don't
anticipate right so here look at
Stockton right Stockton is at risk and
it's interesting because if you look at
this model and then you this is it just
one foot and then you go to seven feet
it's not that different it's still
different but it's not that different
and so these risks of inundation and the
consequences of this are very hugely
depending upon the topography of where
you are and where you know how the
flooding will work in the Bay Area is
very different than how it will work in
Boston how it will work in Legos how it
will work in Bangladesh it's all very
particular this question though of how
fast is the big question and what we
know is that in the past sea level rise
is not something I always had this idea
that it's sort of like like you know
kind of long slow thing kind of like
grandpa driving to the store you just
sort of long slow movement you know over
time it's not in the past it's moved in
these pulses so for example there's this
thing called the meltwater pulse one a
and where the Younger Dryas where you
see a sharp line there we had 13 feet of
sea level rise each century for three
centuries and we know this this is not
hypothetical this is measured in in
Paleo records and things so we know that
this has happened before 13 feet of sea
level rise a century that is
catastrophic I mean that
is you know virtually every coastal city
in the world would be completely
inundated right and and I'm not saying
this is happening now but we know that
it has happened before so one of the
things we were talking about in an
article on the ship was trying to figure
out what the mechanism for that was and
one of the things that might have been
the mechanism for that is what I'm gonna
talk about in a minute and what we went
to look at Antarctica big place big as
the United States and Mexico combined I
always I had given this talk probably
fifty times before I went to Antarctica
and I always said that and it always
sounded good and now that I've been
there and seen it it's like doesn't come
close to capturing the scale of of what
you see when you're there we went to
this place called Thwaites glacier which
is right there and in western an ARCA
very remote place but is the sort of
this one glacier is like the cork and
the wine bottle for the entire ice
sheets of West Antarctica which have
enough ice to raise seas ten feet and it
is this particular glacier and what
could possibly happen there that is the
reason why all these models are getting
higher and higher and this is the reason
why the United States and the British
got together and spent 50 million
dollars which is a lot of money for
climate research to do what amounts to
an emergency research mission to figure
out how fast the weights can collapse
and that's what we were there to look at
this is a picture from the ship I was on
this picture was taken like three weeks
ago from a drone that we had on the ship
and I love this picture because it just
gives you a sense of the scale of this
place that was an amazing day I have to
tell you that was just you can't see but
there were like seals
I mean penguins jumping everywhere and
it was albatrosses and it was like
nature's party that day it was really
beautiful with the water and the ice and
it was and at the same time the sublime
beauty of catastrophe
because we didn't know it and I'll talk
about in a moment but part of the
weights had collapsed in real time while
we were there and we only knew that
because of satellites up but the day
that this picture was taken was the day
that the collapse happened and some of
these Berg's that are you see floating
off or part of that collapse I'll talk
about that in a minute but I want to
talk about why Antarctica is such a risk
in why sea level rise is something that
is very difficult to categorize the risk
on and why these risk scenarios are
getting higher and higher and that's
this idea up until about ten years ago
scientists thought when ice melts as it
does in Greenland it melts the same way
an ice cube melts on your picnic table
on the 4th of July which is that it gets
hot the ice melts it turns into a puddle
and the atmospheric warming is basically
what's doing it well they figured out
about 10 years ago that in Antarctica
which everyone's seen as being a very
stable very cold place no much not much
difference in certain surface
temperature variation seemed fine no
worries it's all about all about
Greenland well no they were wrong and
what they figured out was happening is
that there is warmer water being pushed
up against these big glaciers in
Antarctica because of a slight shift in
the winds due to changes in atmospheric
circulation and those warmer waters are
starting to melt these glaciers from
below and this is an example of how this
works and why it's a frightening
scenario this is just basically this the
all right West Antarctica is like a big
bowl and this bowl filled up with water
and it froze and it's it's chained it's
created these enormous glaciers on this
what's called a reverse slope backwards
scale here - again doesn't do it justice
but if you go back on the bowl of just a
few miles you get to 2 miles thick of
ice that bowls 2 miles 6 via this
glacier is is as much as 2 miles thick
goes back about 400 miles
but this is what it looks like in an
ideal state and what the kind of state
that they had always thought that
Antarctica was in which is that you have
the whole thing frozen you have the
grounding line which is where the ocean
meets the ice and then you have this ice
shelf that sticks out like a fingernail
from the ice that's that's the healthy
ice sheet and that's how everyone
thought it was but then people have
realized now that these ice shelves are
starting to fall fall off and that's we
witnessed that and while we were there
these ice sheets these ice shelves
crumbling and these ice shelves work as
a kind of buttressing for the glacier
itself to kind of hold it back a little
bit and as these ice shelves collapse
the water starting to get under the
grounding line there you can see going
over the edge and it gets down
underneath the glacier and it's starting
to melt it from below in ways that you
can't see from satellites and other kind
of imagery and the scary thing about
this is that as it gets down underneath
there's a phenomenon that scientists
have just really just recognized in the
last decade which is a something called
marina ice cliff instability which
basically says that any ice wall over
100 meters high if it's not kind of
grounded we'll it will immediately
collapse that it can't the physics of
any kind of sheet of ice more than
hundred meters high will fall apart and
so what you have in West Antarctica is
the possibility of a whole lot of ice
collapsing into the ocean very quickly I
kind of run away cuz it's on a reverse
slope backwards so if it starts
collapsing in front it starts getting
deeper and deeper at the Shelf the
glaciers higher and higher and it all
can just fall in very very quickly and
that's what we were there to research to
understand how much water is getting in
how much fracturing is going on and to
try to understand could this happen very
quickly and was this the mechanism that
we saw in that meltwater pulse one a in
the past where we had 13 feet of sea
level rise each century for three
centuries and this is the scenario that
happens you get a runaway essentially a
runaway collapse and this again is
hypothetical this is something that you
know who they just spent 50 million or
they're spending 50 million dollars just
send the best scientists in the world
down there to try to figure this out
because they're freaked out
I mean so it's amazing and so but the
most amazing thing was it happened while
we were there so this is a satellite
picture the red dot on the left is where
we were on March 2nd in front of that's
the way it's glacier there the area in
the dark is of course is open sea where
we were in the ship no humans had ever
been to there before we were the first
people had ever been there we were
mapping the seabed looking at their
water circulation underneath it was
amazing that picture that I showed you
at the very beginning was taken on that
day and then on the sixth four days
later this whole ice shelf and part of
the glacier collapsed as you can see on
the on the right our ship where the Red
Dot is is where we had moved that day
and we didn't know it in real time
because you it wasn't like there was
some kind of big crumbling or some like
there was not a CNN news alert that you
know that you know the glacier around
you is about to collapse but we did
notice a lot more birds coming speeding
by us and all of that and it freaked it
once we once we got these satellite
images and realized what was happening
it freaked a lot of us out because like
we're here to study this sort of idea
rapid collapse and it's happening like
while we're here as if it's like Mother
Nature performing for us and showing us
like what can happen you know there's
some cotton debate about how significant
this really was and whether this was
real time collapse or just a kind of
more natural evolution of the ice shelf
and all that I think that most
scientists that I've talked to agree
that it this is not a sort of sign of a
healthy glacier and so many part of the
collapse process but one of the problems
is no human has ever seen ice sheets
collapsed in this way that they're
talking about here so they don't really
know what to look for and what the oh
[ __ ] signs will be and but I think most
of the people who on the ship certainly
took this as a big oh [ __ ] moment for
sure it's like a third thing I want to
say about sea level rise is that you
know there's this idea that oh oh it'll
be Atlantis you know that'll be like
they'll be cartoons about it and that'll
be terrible but until then we're fine no
it's troubles start very very soon with
flooding and sea level rise
long before Atlantis comes along one of
the problems is sewage systems right
sewage systems require dry land to drain
as soon as you start to get any kind of
modest inundation you have many many
problems with sewage and I don't need to
tell you about the implications of that
with diseases and all that kind of thing
I once went wading through some waters
in in Miami and I was with a scientist
who was measuring the bacterial content
and he'd warned me to wear rubber boots
that day and I didn't wear rubber boots
I went in my tennis shoes my Nikes and
he's like you shouldn't do that I was
like I'll be fine don't worry and so I
went and then he did the bacteria count
and it was 30 thousand times the state
you know level of health it was standard
so I took like seven showers that night
but that's the kind of thing that is
going to be happening and is already
happening in places like Virginia and
places like that where you don't have
municipal sewage systems and you have a
lot of communities on septic tanks that
already happens you get you get marine
invasions of creatures coming in you
know anybody can google octopus in
parking garage
Miami and you will see octopus floating
or swimming around in parking garages
among the BMW's and stuff in Miami and
so you get a transformation of
terrestrial environment into a marine
environment which is can be cool if you
like octopuses in your living room but
if you don't particularly want octopuses
in your living room maybe not so cool
the biggest thing is is real estate and
this is of course the question that I
always get you know should I buy should
I say I mean should I sell when should I
say
you know but it's a huge implications
are huge we're already seeing this in
many places in the on the East Coast
West Coast also and it's happening not
so much because people are seeing
octopuses in their living rooms although
that is a problem I guess for
real-estate values but it's more the
fact that people are starting to
understand that this is real that you
know even among climate deniers there's
the tidal changes and stuff and the the
fact that there's more sunny day
flooding there's more this is happening
more and more and more is making people
think oh you know I think maybe I need
to get out of here because you know the
value of my house which I'd always you
buy a house and you think it'll be there
for thirty years and you think about the
calculation of appreciation and all that
kind of thing and there's all the ups
and downs at the economy but you don't
think oh my house is gonna lose all its
value or half its value because there's
going to be octopuses in the living room
but even the knowledge of people like me
out there talking about the risks of
Antarctica and things like that or it's
beginning and I'm not saying I'm
influencing the markets but I mean
saying that the the awareness that this
is going to be a problem and that hey I
should sell now so I don't lose money in
the future is a real and present thing I
mean I did a talk in Asheville North
Carolina six months ago and there's like
as many people throughout here at this
talk and I was like what are you all
doing here I mean I know it's a good
book but why are you here and they had
all moved from the Outer Banks and they
decided they were gonna sell their place
while there really the value that the
house was still relatively high and
moved to a cool place that was sort of
like the Outer Banks which was Asheville
so this is already beginning to happen
in real time and it has huge
implications as many of you would and
probably know and doesn't need a lot of
work to imagine for tax rates its
property values decline it has huge
implications for tax rates for tax
revenues I mean huge implications you
know because that the problem is is that
you get a decline of
tax revenues at exactly the moment when
you need to spend more money to build
defenses and things like that so it's a
real nightmare scenario for a lot of
communities and I've spent a lot of time
talking to coastal you know city
officials and things who are petrified
about this even in Singapore even in
Singapore I was just in Singapore and
one of the Chiefs of Staff for a for one
of the top officials there came up to me
and told me that they're very concerned
about that they're also of people
deciding that Singapore is too
vulnerable and moving to safer places so
so this is a this is a big problem
that's happening now already long before
the whole Atlantis scenario and then of
course there's just the thing that
people are going to be moving right I
mean climate change is obviously going
to shift our landscape in our map it's
in a big way and as population leaves
from these areas as the risk of
inundation grows you had that same
problem of loss of tax revenues what do
you do how do you how do you provide 911
service to communities where there's
three people living there you know how
what are the obligations for road
maintenance for schools all this kind of
stuff that you get in a kind of Detroit
kind of decline happening simultaneously
in coastal communities all around the
country and the world and of course when
you get migrations of people moving
people moving out of areas you know that
is a the political implications of that
are huge to nobody who's I don't need to
talk about that too much that's
obviously the story of our time right
now of people refugees moving from one
area to the other and it's not just you
know rich people in Florida deciding
that they want to sell their beach house
but people in Bangladesh people in
Africa
moving getting going to other places all
the politics of you know 15 million
people in Bangladesh being inundated and
needing to go somewhere where will they
go are enormous so let's talk about how
we'll deal with this
this idea that you know there's gonna be
billion we're gonna do all kinds of
stuff to to protect ourselves to adapt
to all this some of it will be brilliant
and wealth and good stuff some of it
will be really stupid and waste a lot of
money and hidden you just talked about a
couple of things so this is in Miami
Beach for example right now they're
spending five hundred million dollars to
improve drainage elevate some streets
put in a bunch of big pumps that are run
by diesel engines everybody hates them
they don't want these giant pumps that
are like the size of a semi-truck in
their in their neighborhood with these
diesels running all the time
elevating streets so you have streets in
my reach that are three feet higher than
the storefronts that are down below and
you have these pumps that are pumping
water out in it and it's sort of working
in a kind of half-ass half-assed way it
helps with the drainage it's doing a
little bit better but it's it's five
hundred million dollars there's only
about a 20-block area that's really
being focused on this it's just the
beginning there's already been a lot of
pushback on it too much noise and
construction I don't want to pay more
taxes so it's even in a place like Miami
Beach hugely at threat at risk the the
engineering to do the simplest things is
complex and expensive elevating
buildings obviously you can elevate
anything this is a picture of the tremon
hotel in Chicago being elevated in 1884
no problem they just got like 2,000 guys
with wood screws and it was like a
quarter turn every like 10 minutes and
the 400 room brick hotel they never shut
it down people there's stories about
people having tea while the guys are out
raising the building a little bit of
loot so raising a building is not a
problem right you can raise a building
the problem is raising a city raising a
lot of buildings and then what happens
to your world when you're living in a
higher building and what it where does
everything else go what does that mean
for everything else and you can see
examples of this this is a picture I
took on the Jersey Shore people are out
elevating their beach houses on the
Jersey Shore you know yes this person
will prob
we be fine but you know for a while but
you know what if the guy next to him
doesn't elevate and abandons this place
and it becomes the swampy mold-infested
thing and the roads getting out there
aren't elevated so now you invest in a
seaplane to get out there and the
hospitals are closed because population
has shifted and so there's all these
it's like one thing to take care of
yourself and move your house it's a
completely different thing to think
about the context of this world that you
live in and how do you fix all of that
and you can build walls right obviously
we've been building walls for a long
time
Manhattan after Hurricane sandy they did
a design project where there they're
basically going to put this thing called
the big u around lower Manhattan and at
least that's the theory
whether it ever really gets built or not
we'll see and they know know who is
involved in it likes to be called a wall
it's more like a barrier with amenities
which I guess is a wall with Kevin a
wall with cappuccino but here's an
example in there they are doing really
interesting stuff parks and you know the
building buffers and barriers in a very
interesting way this is the idealized
version of it we'll see what it actually
looks like they're starting with this
area on the on the Lower East Side that
was the most vulnerable it keeps getting
pushed back and pushed back but I think
that will eventually get built but there
are lots of problems with walls right I
mean for one thing places like Miami you
can't build walls but the other thing is
is like if you're if you're building a
wall man Laura Manhattan and the wall
stops at 42nd Street on the Lower East
Side and you live at like 45th Street
you're like well wait a minute you know
why not me let's go three more blocks
you know I'm what about Waianae aren't I
important and then if you live in Red
Hook like you're like well you have
you're paying this like Danish
starchitect you know billions of dollars
to build this really cool barrier with
amenities in lower Manhattan but what
about me out in Red Hook why don't you
spending billions of dollars with Danish
architects out there and so the social
justice issues are huge when you talk
about walls and how you would
how you would build walls and then
there's these fancy walls this is what
they're doing in Venice which one of the
engineers who was working at it calls
the Ferrari on the sea floor which is a
wall that disappears when it's not
necessary so you don't have to look at
it you don't want to Mar the visuals and
then when there's big tides or risk of
flooding the walls inflate and they move
up and they block off the city problem
with this is that they spend about 25
years
engineering it thinking about doing it
they spent it's very expensive seven
about seven billion dollars about a
billion of which went to ski condos for
various contractors and politicians
about 500 of them went to jail for that
but the corruption aside the problem is
they built this whole thing that's just
now beginning to become operational and
they didn't really factor in sea-level
rise so it's like oh really
we forgot sorry so you're building this
huge infrastructure that like after
about seven inches of sea-level rise
will be obsolete and you can't easily
adapt to you can't actually just add an
extension to it in some easy way so it's
like flawed engineering in a big way and
I think a lot of big engineering
projects run this risk of just a kind of
short-term thinking and in the in a very
profound way
and then when you think about how we're
going to adapt and and change our
communities you know the the the these
big infrastructure things are a big a
deal a real big problem and this is the
Boston Airport San Francisco Airport it
was the same kind of thing and they're
all built on landfill they're all built
in low areas so when you think about
protecting a place like the Bay Area or
like Boston or like anywhere you have to
think about these large infrastructure
things and so how do you begin to move
airports how do you begin to you can
elevate airports to some degree but then
you have all the roads coming to them
there's a lot of complexity in thinking
about that it's not just oh we'll just
releve some houses and build some walls
and would be fine
there's train tracks or a big issue and
this all became clear to me when I went
to Norfolk Naval Station which is the
largest naval station in the world I
went there with secretary Kerry a couple
of times Kerry was very aware of all the
risks of this I was standing on the deck
of a battleship on the two hundred and
fiftieth anniversary of the Marine Corps
when Kerry asked the commander of the
base point-blank how long does this base
have to be viable with sea level rise
coming in the commander said 20 to 40
years which when you think about the
scale of this base and what that means
it's huge but what's really important
the message the implications of that are
huge but what's really important and I
would I really learned in going to this
base is that the military has a ton of
money right they can do whatever they
want right they can they can raise the
docks they can put walls everywhere they
can do they can do whatever they need to
do to save the base but it doesn't do
any good if the entire area of around
the base is underwater so if the
railroads that bring all the munitions
and materials to the base are underwater
does it help if the base itself is okay
if the people the 75,000 people who work
at the base if their homes are flooded
or losing value because of flooding and
they're moving away they're not gonna be
able get to work if the streets are
flooded they're not gonna be able to get
to work so the Navy has figured out that
basically to save Norfolk base they have
to save a whole section of Virginia
which is a whole other question for very
for many many reasons but it really
highlights the complexity of the of the
issues here and the last thing I wanted
to touch on with this is this idea that
opportunity comes as disguised as
catastrophe sometimes this idea that I
think that you know one of the things I
learned in reporting this is that yeah
the notion that we have figured out the
perfect civilization that we know we've
done everything right and we can't do it
in a better way is like really dumb and
that this is an opportunity to rethink
our relationship
with communities with land with water
and there's a I met incredible amount of
really interesting people and others
engineers of landscape architects
designers who are thinking and very
profound and interesting ways one of the
things was very simple was this
community center in Lagos which was
built by a Nigerian Dutch architect
you're just using 55-gallon plastic
drums and some obviously some simple
lumber and it was a community center
that was built in the middle of this
lagoon and it was hugely popular very
kind of striking and beautiful
unfortunately it blew down in a big
storm so that was not ideal but it was
never meant to be it was meant to be
kind of a and nobody was heard or
anything but it was meant to be a kind
of prototype and he's building a better
one now but it was a great example of
really simple thinking the in a way that
was completely adaptable and very useful
and inspiring to this community in the
Netherlands I was just there before I
went to Antarctica they are talking
about floating farms all kinds of things
and other ones have figured out they
can't keep building dikes they need to
start thinking about building a floating
world and they're experimenting in all
kinds of interesting ways I'm not sure
that floating dairy farms are where I
would be investing my dollars but
they're thinking seriously about it this
is a rendering of a friend of mine who's
an architect in Miami I asked him to
give me his vision of what kind of
things will be built in Miami in the
future and he has this idea of a
platform city it's based on some
renderings by a Japanese architect in
the 50s uses technology used in oil
drilling rigs and things like that and I
can imagine that this kind of thing will
in some ways happen that there will be
some this is a kind of prototype of some
kind of an alternative future for for
South Florida I visited the Netherlands
where they are rerouting the Rhine River
I had a very big engineering project
because the river because of sea level
rises backing up and flooding more and
more often and so how do they deal with
that they give the River
room to run instead of going around this
curve and flooding into that town you
see on the left
they have built an additional channel
for the river so that when it get the
water gets higher it has a place to go
massive engineering project but one that
really solved the problem in an
interesting way I want to do just
quickly talk about it the there was a
project rebuild design competition in
the Bay Area here one project by Bionic
a landscape architect firm here in the
Bay Area that I thought was really
interesting in San Rafael had this idea
about the San Rafael is very at risk
it's very low and many of you probably
know there's flooding on the highway
there already and how do you deal with a
place like that and the conventional
scenario was you know building flood
walls and levees and protections in that
kind of way but they had a bit an
interesting idea about gradually
reimagining San Rafael and moving it to
higher ground building floating
structures and actually not trying to
wall off the water but adapt to it in
ways and gradually over time so if you
think about redesigning a city and and
sort of reimagining a place over decades
you can make these you can transform it
in ways that are beyond simple let's
throw up a wall and and and protect
ourselves from the water and so I liked
that a lot
another thing that is really happening
around the world that I've seen a lot is
just building new land you know people
are there's a lot this is in the
Maldives but this is happening all over
the world I saw it in Lagos many places
they're just building new high land and
that's one way of adapting is is just
building new land and I think that you
know the value of real estate and things
like that I'm actually surprised that's
one of the big developments that has
happened in the last few years that I've
barely taken by is how many people are
just abandoning old places and just
building new places and that's I suppose
a viable strategy in some levels and the
last thing that I need to just touch on
is this question of geoengineering and
can we use large-scale kind of
technology fixes one idea of
geoengineering
many of you may know about it's putting
sulfate particles in the stratosphere
essentially mimicking artificial making
artificial volcanoes a little bit of
sulfur particles in the stratosphere can
reflect away a little bit of sunlight
and have a pretty powerful if impact on
cooling the earth my last book was about
that we can talk about that more in
discussion afterwards and I know it's an
interest of Stewart's and I think that
there's a kind of inevitability about
this that we're probably going to do it
and but it's not going to stop sea level
rise it's going to hike and have impacts
on surface melting and things like that
but it's not going to cool off the
oceans in a way that is going to have a
huge impact on sea level rise especially
in the scenario I talked about in
Antarctica so it's not a quick fix in
the best and the best vision of it it
can be used as a way to kind of take
some of the edge off warming and maybe
buy us some more time for some of the
other climate impacts would do some of
the surface melting it's a it's a it's a
I think a valuable tool to be highly
controversial tool but a valuable tool
to be considered and probably will be
considered and probably will be used in
the future just to wrap up so I'm just
to wrap up so this question people
always say well what do we do now what
do we do and so one thing I think is
remembering this is not an alien
invasion and there's no little green men
coming out of spaceships with weird guns
that we have to invent weird guns the
gamma guns to kill them or anything like
that all the things we need to do to
deal with sea level rise we know how to
do it's just building differently in
different places changing our
relationship with water
none of this requires massive innovation
it requires different kinds of thinking
different kinds of investment but it
doesn't require magic making risk
transparent for everyone I think is
really important I think that one of the
big problems with sea level rise in
thinking about this is as I showed you
in that inundation map of the bay area
where Stockton was at risk most people
in Stockton I would bet probably don't
know that sea level rise could have a
big impact on their world
same thing with Florida
for example Wes if you look at South
Florida Miami Beach of course is at risk
but a lot of the risk from inundation
there is from the Everglades coming in
so the western part of South Florida is
at risk as the coastal part cutting car
belushin fast isn't really important for
all kinds of reasons that have nothing
to do with sea-level rise all the other
climate impacts but also the degree that
which we can reduce the warming we're
going to reduce the long-term trajectory
and trend of sea level rise and maybe
avert some of the more catastrophic
tipping point kinds of things and then
the final thing is this idea that
retreat is not a dirty word it kind of
is a dirty word and nobody wants to talk
about retreat no politician wants to
stand up and say we're moving our town
back 100 miles but that's essentially
what's going to happen and we can do it
in one of two ways we can do it like
organize thoughtful let's do smart
policy to begin remove ourselves out of
risk or we can do it the Mad Max way
which is like oh [ __ ] there's water in
our front yard let's get out of here and
we know it because this is America which
scenario we're going to do but but
nevertheless it's worth trying to think
about it in a long-term intelligent way
of repositioning our coastline so I just
want to wrap up with one final image
this is my daughter Grace one of the
most profound things that I learned from
a scientist when I was reporting this
book was she said to me
Jeff one thing when you think about
water you need to really remember is
that never to have a fight with a war
with water because water always wins and
she said just go look at the Grand
Canyon so I did and I took my daughter
and this is what water does over six
million years it carves canyons like
this and to me this image symbolizes
everything about everything I've been
talking about the power of water the
promise of the future and our children
and our future generations and that's
really what this story is about
why we're all paying attention to this
so with that Stewart thank you very much
[Applause]
where to begin the thing I that got me
in your book is that you went to these
places you saw things didn't just see
photographs you saw the dynamics of
what's going on there and the shocker
for me is I've been assuming that denial
is something that people can kind of do
at a distance and they can say well you
know statistically maybe there's more
storms but maybe not and you know the
models the models sometimes are wrong
and probably they're wrong on this and
you know the various hand waving that
goes on for denial at a distance but
what shocked me was in many places you
went where the water has already risen
there is sunlight sunny day flooding
going on
and I would've thought okay these are
the folks who've actually realized oh
it's real it's increasing repeat is not
a dirty word I'm out of here but in so
many of these places there's so much
denial in Florida sort of is the little
capital of denial as near as I can tell
political level now it's not a problem
and then it's this sort of real estate
level see a little bit about some of the
things we found on the coast of New
Jersey and the beach house just like you
saw or that you saw on the Florida how
does the real estate thing actually play
currently on the ground well I mean one
of the really interesting things that is
happening that is completely
contradictory to what I ever imagined
that happening is that in places that
have had serious flooding and inundation
they're not like many places are in fact
one place in Virginia that I visited
they're not strengthening building codes
moving people out of the way they're
doing the opposite they're weakening
building codes and encouraging more
people to build their because there's
very afraid of you know this flight
effect you know of people leaving so
they're encouraging them to build by
loosening building code
an opening more land for building and so
in some ways the incentives are exactly
the sort of opposite and until you know
flood insurance and other things really
make it untenable to continue investing
in these places I you know I'm it's
really surprising the the level of we
can just rebuild and and bring it in and
do the way we've always done you know
cuz I think there's also this confusion
that this idea that talked about that
storms and hurricanes are like real ed
in sea level or is like gravity I don't
think people really grasp that I think
they think oh the water came in but
it'll go out again you know so I
remember towards the end of the book II
report on a guy who he's been
experiencing in Louisiana peely Ares of
the government will bail him out in two
ways one is co-payment certain amount of
fraction of the value of this house to
move somewhere else help tame the full
value of the house to rebuild it where
it is right yeah right
there's to all these perverse incentives
and policy things but there's also this
amazing faith that our government will
take care of us and then this is among
like Trump supporters and things you
know I mean the cognitive dissonance on
this issue is so profound you know that
that somehow will get bailed out and
that the government won't let my home be
worth nothing and so I'll get paid
somehow and that is very powerful
everywhere I went
he was mmm even think that Florida would
be leading the way of governmental
taking sea level rise seriously and
dealing with it and and yet it seems to
be the epicenter of no no don't worry is
it's not it's not happening it's not
serious we don't have to do anything
about it
you know what the hell is going on
what's that made of is it well as he
gets worst is the not denial sort of
build a higher wall against the truth
what's going on well you know you're
this organization is called the long now
foundation I think South Florida is the
immediate gratification foundation
basically and in every way right so
there is there is no such thing as a
long anything you know in South Florida
so but I think that that's it so no one
is thinking about that right but but I
mean that's not true there are community
activists there are there is a kind of
growing little consensus there that we
need to take action there is some change
on building codes and I don't mean to
totally take one action well I mean
they're like changing building codes for
example there is some change that's
gonna deal with right right right
525 to 64 right right but but but I have
to say that in some ways this sort of
disposable culture of Miami and South
Florida could is in a way a kind of
saving it's the opposite of Venice right
so you could imagine all of Miami being
wiped out and then just rebuilding it
differently really quickly just like
thinking differently about it all
because there there is no you know
architectural gems there is nobody
thinking about I mean that's not true of
course no I mean I love that Art Deco
and all that but I mean in they've real
in the context I mean no one cares about
that so they could do a vein right they
just don't right
you could bulldoze the whole thing and
start again and that'd be cool as long
as you had Norman Foster building some
of the stuff and you know architectural
gitis were covering it it would be fine
so you could do a combination of a
Venice in the old days when they just
built something that was higher than the
waters right and Lagos where they build
a bunch of stuff that floats yeah and
then you're cool right you get to
continue to have except as you point out
all the whole infrastructure all right
some reports and the roads and all that
stuff or underwater so it it becomes a
completely maritime thing or it's
totally boats together yeah I mean I I'm
not saying I think that's gonna happen I
think you know but it's conceivable but
I think that's also conceivable that
people will just leave you know and just
to what extent are you seeing leaving
you refer to it a little bit there was
more of it actually in your talk than in
the book
are you and you mentioned certainly the
global scales climate refugees are and
increasingly going to be a big event a
lot of places like we stand out to
places like Bangladesh and so on what
are you actually seeing now that is
people actively maybe quietly maybe
noisily maybe in crowds maybe singly
retreating how is that retreat retreat
going forward so far well I think it's
hard to you know really know because
it's very anecdotal and it's very
different in different places but I do
think that you know in the it's been
like seven years now that I've been
thinking seriously about this and
watching this and I do think that people
are really beginning to think about
leaving in ways that they hadn't before
that real estate value is really a
driver's thinking about leaving the act
well leaving both both okay
but I mean it's still not obviously
there's no mass Stampede out of South
Florida obviously but I do think that
this is something that is percolating
through and in a way that is faster than
I kind of had thought that it would be
and and I think that a lot of people I
mean a number of people have are leaving
you know we're seeing that and there's
been some new studies showing some of
that but and I think that's just going
to accelerate as there any scientist
social science population size
demographers looking at the actual
numbers of movement away from rising
waters there's been a few studies but
not very many very good ones know there
has been some better Studies on as I
showed in one of my slides about
depreciation of real estate in some of
these coastal areas and that's yeah
ultimately going to be a driver of
retreat and depopulation of people
moving away yeah although this is sort
of before the fact I want to know who's
moving and where they're moving and you
know Bob public co-packer asks what will
change people to decide to try
geoengineering your former book is it a
pulse of bad news some action by some
nation
or you know if the this is the famous
gradual change problem it's not only low
it's scattered right and different
people are paying attention or carefully
not paying attention to different things
in different ways is any of this up some
kind of a pulse that says okay let's do
some geoengineering and and get serious
that's a good question I mean I don't
know what the mechanism will be that
will trigger that if anything and that
it's same as the same in the same vein I
don't know what the trigger will be that
will make people really do something
dramatic about cutting carbon you know
about we're talking every sign of the
green new deal now which is a great
thing really ambitious you know the idea
of actually taking that politically
seriously and actually doing you know
you're actually building a real movement
around that I don't know that that will
happen but there's there's certainly
encouraging signs I mean I don't know
you know you can imagine I just went to
Antarctica and I just saw a big blowout
and you could imagine if next year
there's a bigger blowout okay and people
start to say oh my god this is this
thing is starting to really fall apart
and you know the blowout that I saw
there's still some argument about you
know what it really means and is it are
we really watching a collapse of a major
ice system in real time or not and but
if it's not far from being able to say
yes we're seeing that and I think if you
had that and you could see images the
way I saw images and you could people
could see that this giant glacier in ice
sheet is falling apart before our very
eyes I think that could trigger okay
it could sweets its weights worst case
goes basically falls apart goes into the
water and erases the water foot two feet
in a decade and what you know what I'm
looking for the pulse of the
cohosh about is there a pulse that might
come out in the Antarctica and is it
then the first of many pulses or is
there a pulse in that we have a chance
to respond or how does how does it look
like that would would occur well it's
not we're not gonna be standing on the
beach and like you know tsunami comes
because a big ice cube fell into the
into the sea in Antartica it's not gonna
be like that but you know like I said
Richard alley
greatest scientist in the world arguably
and very conservative guys as we can't
rule out 15 feet in by the end of the
century and so view that 7 feet by 2015
is that an increasing rate er no I think
we I think it's not I think it's an
exponential rate not a linear rate so
rats in the lower parts clamoring for
catastrophe well in answer to the
question what does it take because this
comes to the fundamental question that
you're seeing in New Jersey and then all
these places our democracy is capable of
responding to a long slow threat like
climate change yeah
sea level rise in particular right
that's a very big question that you know
I suddenly see no indications that it is
but I might be totally wrong because the
not on my watch thing keeps playing out
it right because this short the election
cycles and all the other short-term
political you know impetus and and
motivations are not to deal with this
kind of stuff and not to make the hard
decision about moving San Francisco
Airport or doing the kinds of things the
investments that one needs to do to
really adapt and to change our world and
so it's easy to just keep kicking the
can down the road and kicking the can
down the road
I don't know how that how that gets
fixed um
Singapore versus say Netherlands versus
a Denmark
Singapore's someone when all talk
received carefully non-corrupt are they
taking all this seriously in a way where
they actually do stuff about Netherlands
how about Denmark
well you Singapore has done a lot of
things you know in the way that they've
built but they're still as I said I was
just there and they're still very
concerned about people leaving there
because of the perceived risk of
flooding and inundation I mean I think
China is a great example China has done
a lot of really you know simple and not
simple but things like you know when the
Olympics came they're just shutting down
all the coal plants you know around
Beijing in order to reduce air pollution
and you could never do that in America
right I never just say we're shutting
down all the plants and you know tough
you don't like it too bad you know that
in a way is the kind of thinking that
needs to happen in a way we need you to
say we're doing it differently now and
we're sorry there's gonna be some
pissed-off people but this is the way we
have to go what particular threats from
sea level rise is China facing oh well
they have you know huge threats I mean I
unfortunately would did not go to China
to finish our number of times that I
didn't go there for this book so I can't
give you like on-the-ground reporting on
this but I mean all the kinds of models
show that cities like Shanghai are
hugely vulnerable in the same way the
Delta and inundation all around Shanghai
I mean they have as series of sea level
rise issues as the u.s. no question and
what is the conversation that the
strategic discourse and the government
of China in relation to all this what's
that like no idea I mean I really I just
you know I mean I think they're really
focused on clean energy right now and
they're doing amazing kinds of things
with solar and electric cars and all
that I don't know where the adaptation
sea level rise conversation is and I
don't know anybody who does either
they're playing lots of trees a couple
questions Andy Lee asks what's most
surprised you about Antarctica clay
that's the sort of most recent and it
seems to multiplied and sort of after
your book maybe you're going to do
another book uh-huh
but it's like Antarctica made your
previous book into sort of 5x or
something like that and new level of
seriousness is that what came out of it
North Korea
yeah I mean an arc I'm still processing
it it was such a profound experience and
I think what first thing that comes to
mind is what I mentioned early in the
talk was about this sort of just the
scale of complexity of this system that
were messing with I mean the notion that
Antarctica was Mora has a more or less
been a stable place for thirty million
years I mean there's some debate about
why she retrieved and things like that
but more or less the ice sheets that are
there now have been there for thirty
million years and and you know the fact
that we by burning fossil fuels for 200
years are really messing with that
system and you know these enormous
glaciers that I went right up to in my
in in in the ship and saw you saw that
picture of the the Nathaniel Palmer the
ship I was on in that Bay of icebergs
and just the scale of what's coming I
mean it's just when you think about the
the amount of ice and once this begins
to crumble and become Unleashed and and
what's had the implications of all that
it just blew my mind and I I don't know
how to process it I've been to Greenland
a number of times I didn't have that
response in Greenland at all Greenland I
get it I see how it's happening but
Antarctica is just a whole other thing I
mean it's just Tara Harris I you know 10
years ago I recall when we're all
worried about green don't worry about
the Himalayas but don't worry about it
already yeah that's fine totally and
then we got oh there's one water getting
underneath these glaciers oh we didn't
realize that
and then this idea of marine ice cliff
instability became clear and and now all
of a sudden when you think about what is
the sort of scary tipping points on our
climate system their most urgent right
now in real time for our future I think
most people would say if the weights
glacier is number one or number two you
know I've been up there with the
collapse of the rainforest and things
like that and more data is one is more
dateable more data obtainable than
what's already been done that will be
significant in terms of the ground line
and things like that and is that
research in progress and do you expect
in three or four years time we'll know a
lot more the level of threat from
Thwaite yes I think that we will know a
lot more about the level of threats and
threats but I don't know that we'll ever
I mean we talked about this a lot on the
ship with this ayat with the scientists
you know this is there's no human analog
for this we've never witnessed a
collapse of a major Ice Sheet in human
history it hasn't happened in human
history we don't know what that looks
like we don't know what the signals are
and the signs so it's like mmm having a
theory about cancer or something but
never having witnessed it at all and so
I think that the scientists I know all
the best scientists that I've talked to
they're like you know we don't know
we're gonna be sort of like you know
this sort of blind man and the elephant
in the room and like what is this thing
and how can we figure out if this is
happening on so it may not mean I
basically and I think I basically think
that were we're not going to know that
it's in real-time collapse until after
it's in real-time collapse I mean it's
it's holy yeah exactly
okay that's if you could summarize my
reaction to my trip at an article it was
holy [ __ ]
yeah well Aaron be trying to get these
initial last names interesting says this
all makes me very anxious how do you
sleep
I just elevate my bed a little bit I
live on a boat but how do you sleep at
night I mean hmm you're a you're a
Cassandra you know something is coming
that lots of people pretend is not
coming or say yes I understand it's
coming but it's not that serious
and they're saying actually it is coming
you can't stop it and it is that serious
yeah where does that put you in relation
to the world and you in relation to sort
of to your mind well and also my
relationship with my kids I mean I have
three kids you know and I think about
their world but you know this is a
really weird thing to say but I must say
it anyway is that my understanding of
the fragility of all of this and of the
what's coming has in a way made my my
life and my perception of places is it's
it's improved my life in a big way
why well it's like it's like think of a
relative in your life who you know it's
a kind of a cranky uncle he always
ignore and it's like he's a pain in the
ass and then he would like find out that
here he's got cancer was gonna die in
six months then you start paying
attention to him he's like oh he's not
so great he's a good guy you start
looking at him you're thinking about any
appreciate him and all that it's just
civilization you were afraid - no no no
no this is Miami Beach okay so when I go
to Miami Beach now I walk around and I
think oh I look at it in a different way
I think God this is not gonna be here
for long so I really pay attention and
this is great I take a lot of pictures
and it but it makes it more vivid in a
way and and and I think it's it's it's
kind of a great thing and it sounds
totally weird but it's true it it it
it's like a hanging clarifies the mind
idea it you see it and more clearly
sorry kiss it goodbye it appreciates
being kissed yeah
Don SS Don SX if you had two hundred
billion dollars a year to allocate hard
you use it to help heal
planet and in a circumstance if you're
talking about your context medium sea
level rise but across the board 200
billion Wow hmm is that a lot or settle
I don't know it's I'm trying to figure
out you know III I think of it all I I
don't know what I would do I mean in
that sense I mean we have some money yes
you pointed out the military is all
money in the world they can't save all
of Virginia right so right right
I mean I would probably like do
something like you know and I would do
something about gerrymandering and about
you know political political process and
do change okay that's pretty local well
I mean I just think that you know a lot
of the problems are not dealing with
this are not so much like I would build
sea walls or try to invent some kind of
better solar panels or something I think
that's kind of stuff is being done it's
a lot about how do you change the
political response how do you change
build a system whether it's a like you
question the question you asked can
democracy deal with this and so maybe
one way of thinking about dealing with
climate change is dealing with democracy
and trying to think about democracy and
changing our democracy because certainly
the no MOC Rafi that we have right now
that elected to president like we have
now is not a promising path for dealing
with problems like climate you see you
you talk to the end here about
transparency or risk how do you see that
getting realer for people yeah that's a
that's a hard question yeah you know
that's about kind of education broadly
not about not school of education but
you know governance got the local
officials making it more clear the risk
financial tools becoming more
transparent about about the risk
insurance you know I think once we start
seriously adapting then it makes further
adaptation easier or harder
mmm that's interesting question it'll
depend on sort of how its frame or if
it's framed is well it's okay now we've
adapted this we're okay
like Venice only if it goes up six
inches all of that work and all of that
it just becomes it might as well not
done it right right so it sounds like
what you want people to do is kind of a
horizon doubling where they prepare for
the way they can the sea is coming in a
certain period of time with the
understanding that there is yet more
right with that and so you're asking and
not to a gap once but to take on a
perpetual frame of adaptation about this
whole thing right which is really hard
because I think that I mean it drives me
crazy in the whole climate discussion
and debate is because it's often framed
as how do we fix the climate how do we
fix this problem we're not going to fix
it's not like a broken leg where we're
like oh we just go get some splints with
some solar panels and we'll be okay you
know in a few months we're not going to
fix climate change climate change is a
thing that is we're going to be living
with now in in perpetual time and so how
you think about it in that context is is
really difficult and there's not going
to be a fix for sea-level rise or a fix
for droughts or anything like that there
are going to be various adaptations
various ways of dealing with it better
and worse than others but we're not
gonna fix it it's it's it's our world
now and this notion that you know the
land is here the sea is there and we
live in this in this because the the
world that we see is the world we think
is always going to be there and has
always been there what climate change is
teaching us is that the world is in huge
flux and we're it's moving around very
quickly and we're gonna have to live in
a rapidly changing world and so how do
we think differently in order to embrace
that is I think one of the big questions
at the center of all this that's the
evening thank you very much
[Applause]
[Music]